There are so many new beauty products
being released all the time,
so we gathered some of the most hyped
to test for ourselves.
We're starting off strong with
the KVD Beauty Good Apple
Skin-Perfecting Foundation Balm.
This is the first KVD product
I've seen hyped in about five years
and the first one I've
tried since the rebrand.
This foundation looks
incredible on the skin.
Like, my skin really did look perfected
and healthy, and it's
definitely buildable,
so you can get whatever
coverage you want from it.
However, as an oily person,
I gotta say this was not meant for us.
Which, like, with "balm" in the name,
you probably didn't need
me to tell you that.
Here's what I looked like
at the end of the day.
I looked like a greasy little piggy.
Dry-skinned people, you need this.
Next up we got the Kiss Eyebrow Top Coat,
which is exactly what it says.
It's a long-wearing
topcoat for your brows.
It felt really weird to paint this
on my brows, but I did it.
And it actually is smudge-proof,
for the most part.
Like, I was rubbing hard,
and I saw barely any transfer.
The waterproof claim was also true.
Here's what they looked
like before I showered,
and here's what they looked like after.
Literally no change.
And of course I had to see
if the 24-hour claim was true,
so I went to bed wearing the brow topcoat.
And even though they didn't look
100% perfect the next day,
I do think this made my brow product
last so much longer.
[sighs] Oh, boy, here we go.
The Colourpop Cheek Dew Serum Blush.
I am devastated that this was not
as good as I wanted it to be.
So, I applied foundation to
the right side of my face
and left the left side bare,
just in case it performed better
on one side rather than the other.
And I do think it performs
slightly better on bare skin.
It's just a very oily texture
that didn't seem to blend well
on top of foundation.
And since the color is so sheer,
I had to apply more,
which made my foundation move around,
and it was just a mess.
If you want a better alternative
to something like this,
I'd go for the Em Cosmetics
Color Drops Serum Blush.
I am not a body-foundation kind of person,
so I was nervous to try the
Fenty Beauty Body Sauce
Body Luminizing Tint.
It's basically like a shimmery body tint,
so it adds a bit of color.
I definitely needed a lighter shade,
but this product actually
performed way better
and less messy than I thought it would.
I preferred applying it with my
Fenty face and body brush,
but hands are fine too.
I thought the glow it gave my skin
was really pretty, and
it didn't feel sticky,
which I know a lot of people
hated about the Fenty Body Lava,
which is a similar body product.
It did dry down and felt
lightweight on the skin,
and it said it was transfer-resistant,
so I tried wiping it with a paper towel,
and there was some transfer
but nothing too terrible.
I was very intrigued to
try this brow pencil.
This is the Huda Beauty
#BombBrows Microshade Brow Pencil,
which supposedly has the
thinnest tip on the market.
Here's how thin a brow stroke is
with this pencil compared
to my regular one.
I really liked this.
I kind of like how the body of the pencil
has this, like, diamond shape.
I felt like it was very easy to hold
and maneuver in my hand,
and it also feels more
expensive than it is.
It's one of the cheaper
high-end brow pencils,
at just $17.
But here's the thing:
I think for the amount of
pressure I normally apply,
the thin microfine point
is just super fragile.
Like, I broke it more than once.
So maybe there's a reason that
there aren't more brow pencils
with these extra-thin tips,
but I do like how this made my brows look.